it's so great to welcome back to the
program Darrell Davis author musician
race relations expert and subject of the
documentary film accidental courtesy
Darrell we spoke a bit about the film
before it's released of course since
released on December 9th and in the film
we learn about your history of having
befriended and I don't think I'm
exaggerating when I use the term
converted over 200 members of the KKK
and white nationalist groups and this
solved for people who don't know your
story this dates all the way back to
1983 doesn't it oh yes pretty much it
does but I want to clarify you know that
I never set out to to convert anybody
you know they converted themselves I set
out to find out an answer to a question
that I had that I had since I was 10
years old after a racist incident you
know that traumatized me yeah the
question was how can you hate me when
you don't even know me and at the age of
58 now I've been seeking that answer for
48 years and I found through the course
of sitting down and having conversations
with some of these people who would hate
me for no other reason than the color of
my skin that after coming to know them
and then come to know me over a period
of time many of them began rethinking
their ideologies and converted
themselves now of course you know there
will be those who will go to their
graves being hateful and violent and
racist but but there were those who who
we think their positions and I'm glad to
have been the impetus and the influence
for that but they converted themselves
for those people who as you say
converted themselves maybe with you as
the catalyst or the impetus talked to me
about the extent of the conversion in
other words I could imagine one
situation where someone says ok I've
reconsidered whether I want to be a
member of one of these organizations
like the KKK and maybe most of their
fundamental beliefs and worldview aren't
changed but they say it's just not a
good idea to be part of the group
whereas I could see on the other end of
the spectrum
a wholesale conversion someone who
really rethink s-- their entire
worldview and what they've grown up
believing we're in that sort of range do
some of these 200 plus individuals sit
some sit with a complete conversions
some even come out and speak out against
their formal organization much too
sometimes to their own in our peril and
and and others you know while they have
left the group and and we thought their
ideology some of them still have little
you know twinges where you know they
they now accept let's say they now
accept black people but uh but they have
a thing against Hispanics or Muslims or
something like that you know it's not a
like a light switch just minos switch
off all your prejudices all at once it's
a it's an evolving process I know that
for some of these individuals the mere
act of spending time with you and
getting to know you has a really
significant effect on their views but
going above and beyond that I'd love to
hear from you a little bit about what
types of conversations or exchanges or
questions or statements from you have
been and we're talking about larger
numbers here over 200 people have been
effective in sort of flipping a switch
in people's minds and getting them to
approach an issue differently what types
of conversations well each person you
know regarding why they joined and the
answers will vary some join because my
grandfather was in the clan my daddy was
in the plan so I'm in the clan my son's
gonna be in the clan so it's like a
family tradition others joined because
they're living in an area that is
saturated with that kind of mentality in
order to to get along and become part of
the community they join not that they
necessarily believed in it beforehand
but it was nesting a gang in order to
get to do business you know the local
local gas station guy is head of the
clan so if you want to get your car
fixed there
you know you better be a member it's
kind of thing you know you looking for
each other
others join for socio-economic reasons
for example you take a a depressed town
for example Scranton Pennsylvania coal
coal mining town a lot of coal miners
you know that laid off things like that
and they're out of work but then a year
or so later those same jobs from which
they were laid off have been filled by
by immigrants who just came into the
country mostly a Hispanic and so the
Klan sees that and they seize upon the
opportunity to come to towns like that
and have a rally and that their rallies
and I've seen this person at their
rallies they'll say you know the blacks
have the n-double-a-cp
the Jews had the ADL nobody stands up
for the white man except the plan come
join us
we'll get your jobs back you can't even
put food on your family's table or
clothes and your kids back because
you're not working and some Hispanic guy
and they don't fall in Hispanic guy some
Hispanic guy or such you know has has
your job now these are people who never
had a racist bone in their body and
they're hearing this and they're
thinking you know he does have a point
there well you know what do I have to
lose you know like like Donald Trump
said right what do I have to lose you
know end here yeah they take the
occupation they sign it fill it out and
next thing you know they're in the Klan
and it wasn't because they had a history
of being racist it's because you're out
of a job and somebody is promising them
a better future well we heard that
people yeah we have well I want to get
into that a little bit I mean has have
the conversations you've had with
individuals who have been catalyzed or
drawn in by these ideologies
how has the Trump narrative or rhetoric
infiltrated or gotten into the stories
that you're hearing oh it's definitely
there now you know let me be clear about
something every racist that I know and I
know a lot of raises every racist that I
who voted for Donald Trump mmm however
that does not mean by any means that
everyone who voted for Donald Trump is a
racist of course I have fun I have
plenty of friends who who voted for
Donald Trump who were absolutely not
racist you know but they but they
support it know some of his ideology and
just uh you know that they wanted a
change you know from what had been the
status quo ever since George Washington
or whatever yeah
George won yeah so anyway so it's to
make that point clear
but yes you know Donald Trump spoke the
same language it's the exact same
language pretty much that the Klan has
been speaking ever since their formation
in 1865 they have you know the Klan
formed at the end of Czar of the Civil
War after the slaves were freed 1865 and
they've been you know preaching to get
black people Hispanic people of anybody
non as they call it non-aryan in other
words non-white out of this country this
is a white man's country the
Constitution was signed by white men the
country was founded by white men so
people need to go back to where they
came from and that this being a white
nation-state so they've been campaigning
on that platform
you know since 1865 no other president
campaigned on that and then here comes
the guy who's campaigning on the very
words that they're saying he's gonna
build a wall keep people out he's gonna
deport people out of here who already in
here so he's speaking their language and
Darrell one of the things that was
notable to me about the language issue
that you're pointing out I spoke to
former neo-nazi Frank mink not long ago
and Frank pointed out that if you look
at the text of a lot of Donald Trump's
rallying cries and statements at rallies
if you replace the word Jew with
anything from establishment elitist
immigrant Democrat whatever that the
rallying cries are the style that many
KKK white separatist white supremacist
neo Nazis are sort of used to hearing
except we've just changed some of the
word
that are in there what do you think
about that absolutely I've been saying
the same thing yeah he Frank I know
Frankie and front years absolutely
you're right
and Frankie comes from a from a very
knowledgeable background obviously
because he was a former neo-nazi and one
of the one of the most well known for
money or not will former neo-nazis and
I'll go a step further you know that
language is crafted to to to ring a bell
that's only heard by certain people and
am I tell you what you saw that how many
people in America heard that Bell and
they came and voted for Donald Trump
which is fine that's the best air right
I I don't take that away from them but I
will say this I believe that one word
one word that Donald Trump said if he
had not used that word I believe he
would have lost the election I'm gonna
tell you what that for it is his slogan
campaign mantra was make America great
again and he left off the word again
right not as many people that that Bell
would not have rung for as many people
and what you're implying I'm guessing is
that when you use the word again
immediately people say again like when
and then that really seems to be what
opens up the door to some of this
thinking because every president is now
saying I'm gonna make this country great
I mean who wouldn't say that if you
didn't say it you had no business
campaigning for the highest office in
position in the land you know of course
we want to make this country great but
to make it great again you know that
that is certain code language just like
for example I'll give you two specific
examples how code language works
recently over the last eight years we
saw the formation of a new group
political group of people called the Tea
Party the last time you and I heard of a
tea party was when we were in junior
high school studying American history
and Boston
right right Revolutionary War and all
that kind of thing all right the mantra
the the rally cry so the Tea Party was
take our country back we're going to
take our country back all right that is
a plan slogan that is a clan mantra that
was used by the Klan very very much so
started using it in 1954 when Brown
versus the Board of Education integrated
schools all across the country there
were Klan rallies you can see footage of
them you look up old news footage on
YouTube or wherever you'll see these
these clan leaders standing in front of
a burning cross at a rally saying you
know we'd not take our country back I'm
not gonna let my little white boys and
girl and girls go to school with little
in words okay we're gonna take our
country back back to segregation I'll be
damned if I'm gonna stand for
integration that was all across the
country take our country back and it
meant back to segregation so why would a
party many many years later use that
same slogan because it rang a bell with
certain people it was a clarion call if
you will now when you ask the tea party
well why are you using a Klan mantra why
are you using that take our take our
country back mantras you don't say take
it back to what you don't say take it
back from whom you just say take it back
and so this Ono we're not being racist
what we mean is we're going to take it
back from the Democrats we're going to
take it back to Republican rule okay
that's fine well then why don't you say
will not take our country back from the
Democrats or say when I take our country
back to Republican rule see our Jimmy
Carter was a Democrat Bill Clinton was a
Democrat how come we didn't hear a tea
party back then how can we do here about
take our country back at that time you
put a black man in the White House and
all of a sudden we hear about take our
country back and then most recently
Dylan roof Dylan roof them
man who went into the black church in
South Carolina and and murdered nine
black parishioners for no reason other
than the color of their skin What did he
say
What did he say in his in his hour diary
that was put that was all that was shown
on the knee that's been shown on the
news all week
since he decided to represent himself he
said he wanted to take our country back
he has exact words everybody should
check out the documentary film
accidental courtesy we've been speaking
with Darrell Davis who is the subject of
the film it is endlessly fascinating and
I always appreciate speaking with you
Darrell thank you so much for talking to
us today
anytime my friend